yes dan you're on the air in Hong Kong
yes international yeah international day
love peace and love hey did you talk to
Ronnie on in the limo on the way home
about being Dean painting the body no no
you know what I sometimes listen to the
radio show like I'm sitting in the back
of the car and I'll put the radio on
just to hear what we sounded like and
you know did we get it right or wrong in
my opinion and that was like the second
I put it on was me arguing with Ronnie
about what a dodo-head he was using Dean
Cain's body you see that this is not
your body you know that you're not gonna
claim that that's your body are you I
don't know I don't even remember who
taught you got the same exact red mark
on your chest as Dean Cain okay that's
not your body you know you mean you
haven't known that for five years that's
really I never really noticed it never
thought about it even and I went oh [ __ ]
now what do i do do I turn off the radio
or do I act like this like Ronnie can
hear it got very uncomfortable so I
quickly turned it off then Ronnie was
all excited yesterday I heard because
Dean Cain himself tweeted out yes that
does appear to be my body no Ronnie
feels like he's got a relationship and
cahoots
yeah with Dean Cain now they're friends
kind of - Ronnie I mean in a way all
right so here's what happened go ahead
good night Stephanie reminded me that
said if it's actually seven years ago
that this picture went up that I didn't
know about it and he I somebody said to
me is do you want to use this picture
right and I said yes you liked I didn't
really look at it that closely going
back never look and she said to me no I
mean you looked at a picture of yourself
and then I can explain wait wait but let
me understand this part of it this is
what always happens you never let me
explain first all right go ahead you
always like to rip my throat out no I'm
saying you don't let me you like that a
picture seven years ago of yourself but
you can really look at do you want to
use this picture of you and it told me
not to use it okay yeah but that's a
sexy but hey I look good I said don't
give a [ __ ] just use it I didn't know it
was Dean Cain's body what is happening
with it nothing but she was the one who
reminded me that it was just like a
thing that I looked at a picture some
somebody showed me right they were
making up a poster for one of our block
party shows right do you want to use
this picture I said yeah it's cool use
it yeah and for seven years you never
really saw it as she taught no I saw it
but yeah you don't see that it's not you
know was Dean paint you what see and
that's why she told me not to use it but
Ronnie so you knew it wasn't your body
like I didn't remember okay now wait a
sec it was just admitted that forgetting
yeah of course you didn't know was
dealing with hain like that that ass all
who came in here I don't know what his
problems with me yeah that and kept
insisting that it was a [ __ ] liar
that I was right though I you know Kings
body I say you know it wasn't your body
you know I don't need him calling me a
[ __ ] liar but Ron Stolen Valor
whatever dude I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't like being called a liar I didn't
realize honestly okay
you did realize it you just admitted to
realizing it when you saw it you know
real yeah but I didn't know who it was
but what's the difference was it wasn't
you know you know I'm not a liar I'm an
idiot stupid call me [ __ ] Ronnie how
can you be mad at prison he stay he
called you yesterday who heard it you're
still here is such a [ __ ] benediction
to me for the next injection that it's
so addictive that I was a [ __ ] lawyer
I actually feel bad for you because you
just confused where are you going you're
leaving
run away Ronnie what is that you came in
to talk to him I didn't lie but I didn't
tell the truth Neeta
that doesn't make me a liar just hear
Ronnie's explanation he should apologize
to you he really should we keep him in
the room with you like as soon as you
walk any walks out yes like my lover
yeah did you two break up
I think he's attracted to you all right
Wow yeah you know he sneers at me now in
the hall that's the whole thing
but he's caught you know he don't why he
doesn't want to come in Vince
there's no the defense he should say he
knew it wasn't his body yesterday he
claimed he didn't know I didn't think
I'd be caught what is the big deal dude
you got caught so what you did know you
knew it was someone else's body she told
me not that it was someone else's right
so you know yeah but yesterday you said
you acted like you didn't know [ __ ]
remember when that picture was made yes
that I knew was of course you do when it
was used in that original poster for the
block party you know it wasn't your body
no she told me back then not to use it
right but I didn't know was Dean Cain
like the way you like you're my punching
bag
you're not my punching bag sure feels
like they give a [ __ ] about you or what
you do I don't care why do you keep
walking out of the studio because I
don't want to listen to you I can't
stand looking at you Wow Wow I didn't
know you felt that way about Chris
because he drunk he comes in here with
that vindictive [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
liar you're a liar you're a liar you're
a lot aren't you he caught you in a lie
got a little bit you lie didn't catch me
somebody else here's a gooey [ __ ]
found that before you did all right
let's get the story straight there's no
story to get straight it's it's here it
is it's so [ __ ] stupid so let's get
it off the table
you ready seven years ago you said to
Stephanie
what do you think of this picture she
said don't use it it's not your body she
just said don't use it
right she said it's not your body that's
what you told us five minutes ago yeah
okay that's what she said right okay
take it easy could you like put me on
[ __ ] trial for yes you would do
terribly understand you just you've got
20 different stories I'm trying to get
the one looking guy like he's like some
kind of prosecute your buddy kill shot
Dean Cain confirmed it on I see so why
would you don't see the humor that you
think you're built like Superman I think
I was built like Superman I mean from
what I understand seven years ago there
was a photo shoot of you somehow there
was no photo shoot somebody showed me a
bunch of pictures which one would you
like to use so you must have been like
wait a second which one would you they
show me a bunch of pictures which woman
you'd like to use in the post don't you
think this was over and then you okay
and then Stephanie said don't use it
reminded me last night about it I didn't
[ __ ] really said don't use it because
it's not your body that was last night
no that was yes and whatever part of the
story that we're just learning Howard is
there were several photographs and he
was at college oh yeah cuz I liked the
way it looked it looked cool because it
was Dean Cain not you my [ __ ] face
oh my god I I was trying to get to the
real story I just you know [ __ ] it I
can't talk with you Chris what is going
on here I have no idea he knows
everything so let him [ __ ] tell the
store and I would like an apology
you ain't get [ __ ] from me powered yeah
Ronnie wants you to tell the story you
tell the [ __ ] story ahead because
you're the prosecutor the defender you
know everything from what I understand
yeah I don't know why you're so upset
you got yourself into this mess not me
I didn't do anything
yeah okay I get some kind of [ __ ] big
crime it's dishonest yeah it's very well
it is it is I found out that I didn't
know what I thought that I know
and then Kane didn't approve this doing
now busted are you done
gotcha yeah unless you want to make a
final statement very missing [ __ ]
over here he's got Chris well I'm sorry
too I apologize no I don't want you to
apologize to our fans your catfish yeah
Ronnie's yeah well they were
yeah those of you who fell for it yeah
for the scam that's some scam
Ronnie catfish you it is not his body
lest anyone think that he is built like
Dean Cain exactly I just want you to
know for the guy was trying to fool you
I was trying to beat Dean Cain I
apologize to you my audience who have
always trusted us that one of the people
I work with right
misled you right and he's a [ __ ] liar
I'm using your words he is Chris's
[ __ ] world alright yesterday I
apologize if you show up to Ronnies gig
you're gonna meet somebody who isn't
built like Dean Cain don't look at my
arm right he is if you think it's being
caned don't come Robin are we calling
this a closed case or I think we have
all the facts whether Ronnie wants to
admit them or not I admitted it okay
[Music]